[Music]
we are back we're here
and we are ready to take a roll call and
another edition of roll on
with my bestie my hype man adam skolnik
journalist environmentalist
large personality here
oxygen room room certify us and soothe
our soul
in another conversation about
semi-current topics
yeah interest pertinent and possibly not
depending upon how this goes
it's all depends on your point of view i
guess how are you doing
i'm good man good i've been uh able to
get some actual exercise
this week and like you know out there
five six days and
and i did it did a six mile
swim run nice fun which was kind of the
first
long like not long but uh how's the
sleep you're getting you're able to bank
a little bit so you can't get out there
sleeping like maybe
he's sleeping like six and a half hours
one time and now like
then four hour shift but much much
better um
yeah he's he's growing he's really
growing up that's cool
yeah well good to be back with you a lot
has happened since we last sat down
in our personal lives and in the world
of course uh before we get into it
um be sure to hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already
i appreciate that hit that notification
bell so you can be alerted when we post
a new video
what we do here is we break down some
events of the day
we kind of share some stories from our
personal life there's a loose format
that's continuing to evolve i suppose
and we answer in the second half we
answer listener questions so if you'd
like your question
considered for us to discuss you can
leave us a voicemail 424-235-4626
so last weekend i was in austin yes
my uncle who is my dad's older brother
is in his um final days of life he's
somebody that
i'm not super close with but my dad
wanted to go out
and be with him for the last time and i
went out
to do the same but also to support my
dad uh
so the circumstances under which my
first experience
traveling were right not exactly you
know
fantastic but it was really nice to see
my dad
and i'm really glad that i went um it
really
brought us together brought us much
closer we were
able to have some deep and meaningful
conversations about life
yeah and it just reminded me how
precious life is and also how fleeting
it is
and how when these moments arise these
opportunities to
you know be with the people that you
love how you have to seize them
and i wasn't looking to jump on a plane
and travel
in the middle of a pandemic i haven't
been on an airplane since this whole
thing began
but i was willing to kind of roll the
dice to
have the experience that i had and i'm
glad that i did it was it was meaningful
i posted about it on instagram you said
your uncle was
actually upbeat too right or you it was
my uncle
was uh well he was
alert and um
basically looking at
maybe another 24 to 48 hours unless
he wanted to have a feeding tube
inserted
because he wasn't able to digest food
initially he passed on that which is why
my dad and i jumped on a plane at the
last minute to go see him
he changed his mind and decided he did
want a feeding tube
so he's still with us now
um although it's kind of up and down so
i was not able to actually
see my uncle after all of that because
they would only allow
one person a day to visit and i didn't
want to take up
that day spot because he had his kids
coming into town
from all over the place and i just felt
it was inappropriate
but i was there for my dad to basically
be with him for the better part of the
day where he at
so my uncle is like eight years older
than my dad so my dad grew up as the
youngest and
there was a lot about his older
brother's life that he didn't know
and he wanted to ask him before he
passed so that was kind of a cool thing
that was cool yeah how did he how did he
handle everything was he pretty
emotional
my dad was yeah my dad was yeah and my
uncle was
still is he's still around an amazing
guy he
um went to yale and then he got his phd
in physics from princeton
in the department that was made famous
by einstein
who had since retired by the time my
uncle was there
but that legacy kind of still lived on
like it's this amazing program
uh and the beautiful mind guys yeah and
he went on to
design like the help design like the
nuclear
power plants for for submarines like
he's you know he's like a genius yeah
exactly and he was also
an expert at the french horn who
probably could have been a
really musician so he's an amazing guy
yeah that is amazing yeah yeah
um but one thing about being outside of
los angeles and being in austin
was just a reminder of what a cool place
that is i was able to go
swim at barton springs the pool was open
um
running around the lake and yeah and
just being in kind of a little bit more
of an urban
environment uh then i'm used to living
out
you know in the countryside out here it
was nice and and definitely
lifted my spirits it was interesting
though i thought i would have thought
um there would be you know a lot of
people
uh pushing back against the mask things
and basically
everyone was wearing masks except the
guy who decided to sit next to me on the
flight home
what you can't take your mask off on a
plane right i mean they make a big
announcement like you've got to wear
your mask unless you're eating or
drinking but he ordered a cocktail
and then proceeded to nurse that
cocktail for almost the entire flight
and kept his mask off for the whole time
sheesh they should put like non-mask
wearers they said you could
you can fly but you're gonna have to fly
in the cargo hold or just
exert a little bit of courtesy like put
your mask on in between
sips if you're gonna sip this thing for
the entire time
you should get a time limit with your
drink but i got tested
when i got back i'm i'm fine but it was
a little bit hectic so we didn't have
traveling yeah yeah that's where you
were you stressed going in was it was it
was the airport like a ghost town or
that was it pretty busy
um i haven't been in an area well i was
in i had connecting flights because it
was a last minute reservation
flying back i had to fly through phoenix
and that airport was mobbed really that
was
a little bit dicey crazy being around
that many people
yeah but it was good i had a cool
experience um
when i was swimming have you have you
swam at barton springs no i've never
been to austin
so it's this amazing one of my favorite
pools in the world
it's it's basically crafted out of the
lake which is really a river
right an outdoor pool that i think was
built
as a public works project maybe as part
of the new deal okay
quite certain um but you're it's like
swimming in a giant quarry that's maybe
i don't know 300 350 meters across
[Music]
and i'm swimming and i get to one end
and i'm kind of catching my breath
and this guy swims up to me um probably
about my age maybe a little bit older
and he's like hey i love the podcast he
wants to talk about the podcast and
turns out he's a retired army colonel
and master flight surgeon who had been
deployed to afghanistan and iraq and
jordan like all over the world and and
from what i gather like was a pretty
high-ranking
military officer for a long time who's
now living
in galveston i believe
and is the chief medical director for
um this kind of burgeoning industry
that's popping up around
space tourism like space travel like
he's from what i understand and i might
have this wrong he's in charge of like
trying to
um create the systems and the
infrastructure for how you're going to
medically screen people when eventually
you know they're going to get on these
spacex or virgin galactic
flights and go into orbit going to the
orchard is pretty cool and the reason i
bring it up
you just have like a heavy medical
screening for that right you can't just
have
i would imagine yeah you know i would
imagine my point being
that uh every time i think i have
a handle on who the typical podcast
listener or viewer is i think oh
people that are eating a vegan diet or
they're into triathlon or running or
you know being in nature like an army
colonel isn't the first person that
comes to mind
no and it always is touching to know
that
there's a a broader diversity in the
people that are
tuning in than i would have suspected
which i think is great that's great and
it
shows you the breadth of uh people that
are interested in this subject matter as
well yeah so it's like gives you kind of
hope about
the world too for sure people from all
walks of life interested
yeah i'm sure someone's listening to you
and uh in a prison somewhere
uh i've gotten i've gotten emails from
people in prisons which is wild
yeah yeah so what do we got today what
do we got
we got uh well i think you have
something special that you want to talk
about
it's uh you got a book out or come about
to come out i do
yeah i do it's been a big past couple
days
first of all we launched a brand new
website so i want to thank
all the people at emory agency who have
been working hard behind the scenes to
create the next iteration of
richroll.com
we launched the first version of that
last night
so that's pretty cool and we've got a
lot of bells and whistles to come
basically what i want to do what we're
working on is twofold one is
taking all of this content that we've
created in the eight years of doing the
show
and better organizing it so that the
site becomes an educational destination
in other words breaking the podcast into
categories
that align with very specific topic
headers like the microbiome or addiction
and recovery or meditation
and then organizing the top episodes in
each category
accordingly and then also providing
additional resources like books and
documentaries and
other ways for people to more deeply
immerse themselves in that specific
subject so
we're working on that now that will
launch soon and also
this new subscription offering that i'll
get into later but the big thing today
in addition to the podcast with matthew
mcconaughey dropping which is very
exciting yes i was talking about that
we were watching a little bit of that
this morning and uh at the house so
yeah it's amazing yeah it's very cool
what's funny about these things we'll
get into the book in a second but what's
what's interesting
is when i scheduled that which was a
while ago
i should have realized that he was going
to be on every podcast because he bet he
was on every
television show there's no reason why he
wouldn't pop up on every podcast
but for some reason i deluded myself
into thinking i had not an exclusive but
maybe
uh you know maybe an in-road that other
people didn't have and then of course
he's on
all the top shows which is great he
should be right so my hope
i mean i haven't listened to all those
other episodes but my hope is that i got
some interesting uh things there
that are a little bit different yeah
what you're gonna find in the other
podcast my question is how do dan
buettner and
matthew have the same nickname for each
other i know
i i think seems weird that seems strange
i know well i think i think matthew was
the one who came up with the nickname
for dan
and then dan just you know as matthew
said boomerang get back onto him
i like that dan thought he was bradley
cooper for like three days
but you have to understand dana's the
most charming person you're ever going
to meet
and he does all of that like on purpose
it's hilarious so
i went up i went up and saw dan in santa
barbara the other day and
rode mountain bikes and went hiking with
him which is yeah i saw that
that's cool he's such a beautiful guy
he's awesome um in any event
the book voicing change he's in that
book
dan isn't that yes matthew is not but he
will be in a future iteration
voicing change is this book that i
basically
completed during the pandemic that we're
self-publishing
it's essentially a compendium of the
podcast timeless wisdom and inspiration
lifted from the show itself and the
motivation behind it really was to
create
a keepsake for the fans or a way to
go back to meaningful episodes and
see those words that were uttered
auditorily obviously
in print as a reminder and also as an
introduction to people who are not
familiar with the show to get a sense or
an idea
of what it's all about so basically we
took
50 guests that we've had over the years
which was no
small thing to try to figure out who
would be most appropriate of course 20
years ago there's going to be people
it's been eight years coming up on eight
years yeah there's going to be
people missing that are certain people's
favorites etc like you can't
you know it's like 50 out of 550
you know you're you're not going to be
able to hit everyone but i think we got
it we canvassed a really good
cross-section
of the people that we've had and we
transcribed all of those
episodes and we took out we lifted out
the most
kind of relevant pertinent impactful
things that those people said we put
that in there
i wrote introductions for each of the
guests some of the guests
contributed essays like russell brand
yeshka
bali john joseph a couple other people
and there's you know some my friend jeff
gordanier wrote the introduction i'm
really proud of it and it's really a
coffee table book it's a beautiful book
it's a beautiful book
the idea is you can leave it out yeah
it's like like like
art it's art book quality so here's for
those that are watching on youtube
here's the box that it comes in which is
kind of like a pizza box
yeah you open it up here's the book
just like that um lift the book out i'll
just take this one
and you can see i'm not going to go
through the whole thing especially for
people that are listening but you can
see it's you know there's beautiful
photographs
it's really you know meant to be open to
any page and you can kind of enjoy
was it hard to figure out in the lineup
like did you move the pieces around
like where to put the different people
and like build a crescendo
or or like have or did you put all the
athletes in one section
all the no we curated it i tried to mix
it up kind of like the way that we do
on the podcast itself like not not too
much of any one thing in a row
yeah um and you know making sure that
there's a a
an appropriate ratio of you know males
to females and
and the like so um really proud of it it
was certainly a team effort
everybody you know who who i work with
on the show worked very hard to put it
on i didn't do it myself
so very excited about it it is
officially
available for pre-order now pretty
exclusively
on my website we're not selling it on
amazon or barnes and noble like i said
we're self-publishing it
from we're shipping globally you can
ship it anywhere we have flat shipping
within the united states for ten dollars
and of course it's more expensive if
you're
international and it's only a print only
print yeah only print
no kindle or digital you know what it
reminds me of it reminds me i remember
when i was younger i was like
super stoked on this uh playboy
interview
collection like um anthology was like 50
years of the playboy interviews
and that's what i think about with this
book but obviously from
your your perspective because i've
always told people i think you're one of
the best interviewers in all of
broadcasting
that's how you got this job
to my ego i told you that yeah you got
those emails
um so yeah so i think it's it's so
perfect to to have have that kind of uh
as like a complimentary to the podcast
that are coming out
you can go back and look at your
favorites you know i know i i think of
some of my favorite episodes still so
um yeah i appreciate that i mean it's
it's really
you know just a way to canonize
um the mission of the show
uh to further honor all the guests
uh and also to honor the audience you
know to give them
a little piece of this do the guests
know that they're in this beautiful book
yeah i mean we had to get releases from
them and talk yeah
they all know and they're all being
shipped to book right now
they're not gonna be surprised yeah yeah
um that role guy put me in his book
right
um no they all had to sign off on it uh
including your boy goggins yeah we're
gonna talk a little bit more about him
in a minute uh
the book is shipping november 10th
um but it is like i said available for
pre-order now so if you want to learn
more about it
um and reserve your copy go to
richroll.com
vc or voicingchange.com i like it
check it out super proud of it and i
want to thank everybody who
i worked with who worked very hard to
create it it's a beautiful book
nice work yeah man so cool
moving on there's another big thing
coming up
that we've all been thinking about we
can't help but think about it
it's everywhere even if you're not in
the united states
even if you're not which you know right
that's what's so funny is that but it's
not that
like so the debate people in australia
watch the debate
right and they like it because it's
entertaining i remember when rob ford
was the mayor of toronto
right i loved rob ford stories i
couldn't get enough rob ford stories i
love them because he was so
wacky and he they couldn't get rid of
him and and now
we have uh not a rob ford but we have
our own situation where
people who don't live here think it's
hilarious yeah
yeah yeah with very real world
ramifications
very real world ramifications it affects
everyone um
but uh we have a week to go
this is a very unique moment in history
we've never seen anything quite like
this before i mean because we weren't
around during the woodrow
wilson pandemic yeah uh what do you
think
where are we in this moment rich i think
we're at
a very important turning point in the
history of our country
and i want to say up front that this
podcast has never been
a political podcast i'm certainly not a
political pundit
and for anybody who's been tuning in for
a while there shouldn't be any confusion
about where i stand on all of this
but in the event that it needs to be
said i'm
casting my vote for integrity and for
character
and for the environment and for
stability
and so i'm voting for joe biden the
biden harris ticket
yeah and i think it's really important
irrespective of your politics that you
take a stand for character and integrity
and that we uh dispense
with this narcissistic ego maniacal
compulsively lying orange goblin and
vote him out of office once and for all
so that we can move forward with some
level of cohesion
for the future of our country yeah here
here man
the way i try to explain it to people
who are maybe leaning trump and i don't
know that many but i do know some
and what i try to say is if you care
about the ocean
and you care about the environment you
cannot vote for
it's it's voting for trump is the
opposite of that
because he's already trying to reduce
the size of marine protected areas he's
trying to open up
previously protected land to development
he's waving environmental laws to build
a border wall
there's so much i could go on and on and
on if you care about the ocean
you care about the land you care about
animals there's really only one vote you
can possibly make and that's not even
getting to the part if you care about
people and i think the divisiveness that
you're mentioning
it's time to vote for love over fear
one guy's kind of playing into this big
the big hack and helping to divide us
and helping to hack us
and uh the other guy he's not the most
captivating candidate we've ever had
yeah i mean
it's not like you know biden is
the choice candidate of all time i'm not
saying that but
to the people who you know leave
comments and
and point out all of you know biden's
misdeeds or
or you know his failures or
uh you know why he's not perfect that's
not
the decision that we're here to make
we're not adjudicating that right now
we're adjudicating between
trump and biden and so who is it going
to be
you know he's biden for whatever you
might think of him
and the debate stage is not necessarily
the best place for him to reveal his
gifts
but he isn't he does seem like a nice
guy
and we could use a little more nice guy
he's certainly a
a decent a decent human being yeah who
has a heart
and is capable of compassion yes and
i think we need a little bit of that
right now but
we don't know what will happen a lot
could happen um
you know i'm optimistic so far the uh
turnout in the mail-in voting is through
the roof in terms of
youth doing it that is a good sign but
there's also this
idea that uh mail-in ballots always skew
blue it's called the
what is it the blue shift and um
the the night of the election the
election day ballots
um could be could reveal a trump victory
at first that would shift
later which could be problematic um so
we don't know how it's going to go it
could take
a day to find out who won it could take
weeks it could take
over a month uh i think that we're
uh so used to knowing that day
that and and somehow if it takes longer
it seems more suspicious when in reality
it seems like the longer it takes we
should trust the result more
but we're just not wired that way no the
longer it takes
the the more we so distrust in those
results and i think two things i mean
i think first of all it's highly
unlikely that
we're going to have um decisiveness
at the end of election day yeah i think
it's more likely than not that it's
going to take weeks or months so the the
election is certified on december
9th right yep um so that's
december 9th or 14th i forgot i can't
remember it's somewhere around that time
i think it's unlikely that we'll that
we'll know before that date but my hope
is that
upon that date that we will have some
level of certitude
and the second thing is short of a
landslide
and with the foundation that trump has
been laying
around distrust of results
what happens in the event that and i i
think
you know potentially likely event that
he just decides he's not going to leave
right well there was um so there's a
great radio lab episode we can link to
that's called what if
that came out and um my buddy reese
pacheco at wslpure
sent me that so shout out rhys and
they did these war games with some
washington
insiders you know people who worked the
pentagon people who worked for the
democratic
party michael steele the republican um
i think he ran the republican party at
one point a bunch of people that you've
heard the names of
and some people you haven't but have
higher up in in washington
they got together and they did kind of
war game scenarios
like where they'd actually roll dice
like it was a little d
a little kind of brainstorming you know
war room stuff
and uh different people got divided up
in teams and they played
i'm biden campaign i'm the trump
campaign i'm so-and-so and so
so and uh they reveal the due takeaways
are
it is possible that um
a governor or legislature in a state
level could send
electors that are not bound
by the popular vote in a state although
the supreme court has
ruled that's unconstitutional that could
still happen it is possible
it's also possible that the joint chiefs
of staff can decide who they trust to
give the nuclear
codes to and they have the power to take
them from
trump and give them to biden in a
disputed election
so all these things could there are what
if scenarios
i mean i personally am optimistic about
a blue a big blue wave
um but you know what do i know i thought
we'd win
yeah i thought hillary clinton would be
the president well
if we know anything it's not to uh put
too much trust in
the way things have gone down in the
past yeah and that truly anything can
happen and we need to be prepared for
anything happening
which brings me to the new segment the
quick five
are you ready for the quick five i'm not
sure i am
this is the quick five you're just i'm
screaming that you're springing this on
i'm going to give you i don't know where
this is going to be
i'm going to give you a subject
and i want a quick five takes from you
five
things from the top of your mind okay
all right
quick five so tell me why explain to me
why no matter what happens on election
day whoever wins
even not election day whoever wins the
election period why everything will be
okay
um have you ever seen that charles and
ray eames uh film
the power of ten i have not so
it's a little short film that these
does the designer the legendary designer
couple yeah create all the furniture and
architecture
created it's it's on display it's on
permanent display at the air and space
museum in washington dc
which is where i saw it as a kid and i
never forgot it but it's basically
a telescoping up from somebody
sunbathing
in a park in florida and it moves
upward in altitude at the power of 10
like every
at interludes of a couple seconds or
whatever
so you until you see this person you
know
like a drone flying above them and then
from
the perspective of an airplane and then
from orbit
and then you just further and further
distance yourself from them
until you gain some perspective on just
how
small all of us are on this tiny
little blue orb hurling itself through
space
and our biggest problems are then placed
into
proper perspective over the
course of history you know regimes have
risen and fallen you know empires have
uh you know dominated the planet and
then
been overthrown humanity somehow finds a
way to prevail
so that's one so basically in the
greater scheme of things
i think we're going to be okay the
greatest we're dealing with something
that's very dramatic
yeah not uh you know not to like
diminish i think um the impact of
what's going to happen can have on on
everyday lives
all over america and the world and what
has happened of course but
we have air to breathe we still have
clean water to drink
which we're gonna we're gonna get into
more about that in a minute and
we can all find things to be grateful
for and there are only so many things
that we have control over we can cast
our vote
we can make our voices heard we can
assemble
we can do all of these things that we
have fundamental rights to do
but ultimately we have to find a way to
trust and have faith in a plan that
exists lives and breathes outside of
ourselves and to continue to live our
lives
um with some level of peace that we
can't control
everything so let's see if we have five
things one is
this is all smaller than we think it is
when you look from space this doesn't
register
right to the center that's kind of
nihilistic though
yeah but i kind of like it it's a little
dark but i like it yeah um
then you have we have the air to breathe
we have water to drink
if we have food on the table if we're
feeling safe that's
you know we can we have each other and
we have each other
then you said something about uh
the serenity prayer essentially yeah
understanding and appreciating that
there's only so many things that we can
control and those things are very
limited
so if you remember that and you control
what you can control
then everything will be okay in your
world right
and also that every problem doesn't need
to be
your problem and what i mean by that is
we're all in some sense victims of a
news cycle that wants us to believe that
every problem is our problem and it
ratchets up our anxiety but doesn't give
us
a productive outlet for that energy yeah
right
so we don't have to hang on
every facet of the new cycle yes you
know i didn't watch the second debate
because my mind's made up i didn't
really need to see it
i caught some clips of it later but i
don't need to
be informed at the micro level on that
specific decision because i've made that
decision
yeah and i don't need to ratchet up my
anxiety and
and you know threaten my own sort of you
know sense of equanimity
over that event you made the right
decision
because i was watching it with zuma and
about 20 minutes in he
he he expressed exactly how i felt about
it
when he threw up all over my shirt
right and are you better for having
watched it
no it's not as if you were gonna buy it
it's not as if you were gonna change
your mind
no and the problem the reason i don't
like it is because god
biden's great but he does have because
he has
a history of stuttering and it's harder
for him debate format's not a great
place for him and then trump is the more
commanding presence
and unfortunately people are drawn to
that so if you're a supporter of biden
and you
really want this thing to change it's
only going to drive your anxiety because
you're going to look for reasons why
perfect example of something you can't
control right
but the one thing i would also that's
great by the way what you just said is
that like basically keep it
into you you can't make the world's
problems your problems all the time
you got to get through your day um and
that
and that's one way making it okay right
you do have the control to make your
life okay to make your life better
on the individual level at least we do
here and that's one thing i think
um a fifth thing i'll add a fifth thing
for you is that
remember when the covid started and
like the empty there were empty shelves
everywhere in the grocery
store and people were terrified that
like
you know they were building the remote
hospital at uh doc wyler state beach and
i was
joke texting with my buddy i'm like hey
dude if i end up in a trailer in
dockweiler please come get me
right and he's like right too and so
that kind of thing was happening we were
we were all kind of wondering what was
going to happen next but the food
systems did not break down the power
systems did not break down
we did not break down we had people step
up we had people in hospital step
up there are good people throughout this
country
in every city and every town trying to
make it work
and not trying to divide but trying to
make it work and that
is what i rely on we are bent but we are
not broken
and no matter what happens we won't we
we won't be broken
yeah and that's that's my uh i believe
that we won't and so that kind of faith
i have
um it's not even a spiritual faith it's
just faith on what i've seen
with the caliber of people that do exist
in this country on
in both parties and that we we can be
bent but we're not gonna break
yeah and um that's what's happened so
far i think that's a great point yeah
um i believe we talked about this
previously i can't recall but
we have this sense that or many of us
have this sense that that
twitter and these social media platforms
are a proxy for where
most americans are mentally emotionally
and in truth twitter is like two percent
of the
american population or two percent of
the american population is on twitter
right and we we we over index
for the importance of the conversations
that are going on there
as a litmus test for the conversations
that are going on
at you know the panera breads across
america and i just don't think it's
accurate
and as somebody who you know just
traveled and was in a bunch of airports
and
you know talking to a lot of people
along the way i'm always
left hopeful from those exchanges
realizing that
the tactile one-on-ones that you have
with people when you
go out on the road are very different
from
the picture that gets cast on social
media
which gives us uh you know this
this sense that we're more fractured
than i think we actually
are yeah i think we are being tested and
our systems our institutions are being
challenged and they are being bent but
i have faith in our democratic processes
and i think that democracy
is more resilient than perhaps we are
willing to
trust at the moment and we're going to
find out but
i don't think that we're on the
precipice of democracy completely
failing
i don't believe that and even though we
talked about kindling and civil war
i don't think we're going to have that
either because quite frankly
that takes a lot of effort and americans
are not really
going to leave netflix in the couch to
go fight a civil war over
a presidential candidate i suspect there
will be whatever happens there'll be
skirmishes there'll be skirmishes
um but i don't see that escalating
into you know some kind of systemic
cultural warfare that's going to
you know betray our institutions
wholesale i agree and i think that what
you were just talking about relays to
there was an op-ed
by some political scientists that i read
in the new york times i think
the last couple of weeks and it was that
it talked about that twitter percentage
but it also talked about
that actually 80 of americans don't
don't give a about politics even
now
even with this we're supposed to be so
polarized but 80 of americans actually
are not that polarized they're kind of
in the middle
and it used to be when i was kind of
really was in my activist days before i
was
uh writing for a living that kind of
thing would be discouraging
because you'd think oh god 80 of people
are apathetic
but now it like is comforting yeah yeah
people just want to get on with it you
know and that's actually comforting for
me now
and um you know i don't know what that
means maybe it's because
i'm a dad now or something or i don't
know you're getting soft i've gotten
soft
revolutionary streak is yeah but my feet
are still are still not soft yeah i'm
not tenderfooted
well we'll have more information in a
week
we'll know we'll know we'll know next
time for the for the
election i'm glad i'm glad it's
happening yeah we're getting to the
point and to kind of close this section
out i mean just
you know look regardless of your
political perspective go and
have your voice be heard yes cast your
vote
um and participate in this democratic
experiment that still
is continuing to evolve just know if you
vote for trump you hate whales and
dolphins
and baby dolphins okay just kidding
all right what do we got next
[Laughter]
um that was a joke friends um
so next the big story i think that kind
of like this whole thing with the
election
it kind of teases to this theme of
um we need to be responsible for
cleaning our own house for taking care
of our own
and like making sure that we really
close the loops within ourselves and
with our communities and within our
country
and this story kind of gets into that in
a way it was it
it's a story about
dd barrels of ddt that were discovered
in the deep water 3000 feet deep um
but in the channel between catalina and
palace verdes
and which is essentially for people that
don't know just off the coast of los
angeles
it's about what is it like 28 miles from
yeah
from palos verdes to catalina yeah and
it's somewhere in the middle there in
the channel and 3000 feet deep they
they dumped these barrels some of them
were actually hacked with a an
axe in order to sink them because they
were floating
and so they were just leaking they're
just leaking this was in the 70s
yes uh even before that i think it was
prior to the
somewhere between the 40s and the 70s
because it was over a period of time
but um so this was i think pulitzer
level reporting from rosanna shia she's
an environmental reporter at the new
york at the la times excuse me it's the
only time story
and um and it kind of points out that
ddt is this nightmare that never ends
for those who don't know
i'm not going to try to pronounce ddt
i'm not a scientist and i'd screw it up
do you know how to pronounce that word
it's a very long word it's the longest
word i've ever seen i don't
but it was uh it first was synthesized
in 1874
became um a swiss chemist kind of
uh discovered the its insecticide
properties and then it was deployed
in world war ii by the allies to control
malaria and typhus
among troops and civilians mostly in the
south pacific
and uh and then it was
deployed as an insecticide as a
pesticide all over the united states and
it was kind of responsible for the
agrarian revolution all this food you
know
people gave ddt props for allowing us to
grow incredible amounts of food and
export it yeah
and um kind of fuel prosperity is what
people thought
it was it's basically the the precursor
to
what would later become glyphosate
right it was the og
pesticides right right and by the way
it's dichloro diphenyl trichloroethane
all right i believe is how you pronounce
it so paul hermann
mueller from switzerland he's the guy
that first kind of found these exercise
properties but strangely
he was not in favor of of utilizing it
as a pesticide because he knew
that we don't know how it's going to
interact with life and we don't we don't
know the law and it needs to be studied
for years
and um he was right of course that you
know
that that it should have been discovered
for years because then sometime around
a marine biologist named rachel carson
you probably have heard of because of
her books
silent spring she was able to
trace it or posited that this
rampant use of ddt and pesticides in
general
were killing birds and you know not just
any birds but
peregrine falcons bald eagles lots of
birds and
and like all of a sudden the sky was
silent in spring she was a marine
biologist by the way
her book the sea around us which was
published in the early 50s is actually
absolutely incredible i read it recently
won the national book award
she's amazing she's like on that mount
rushmore
of women in science with jane goodall
and and uh sylvia earl
right and and basically ddt is almost
entirely responsible for
the near extinction of bald eagles right
which is crazy
that is crazy and and certainly it
chased them from the channel islands
here
and so basically this company in la
after
the war montrose chemical corporation
opened a plant in torrance in southern
california here
and they cashed in big on the ddt uh you
kind of boom
and the u.s used to it used to make 80
million pounds of ddt every year
that's incredible um and then anyway 19
after carson's book 1972 that finally a
law was passed saying you can't use ddt
anymore it was
it was traced to harming the environment
and and human health and human health
and then um
yeah so it's crazy basically
there was some of that ddt was getting
into the sewage system
and flowing offshore right around palace
verdes in 200 foot deep water very
close to shore that became a superfund
site and that was very
you know montrose chemical company and
the epa weren't a big legal battle over
that
but no one really paid attention to the
fact they were also dumping barrels of
the stuff
in the deep water right that was kind of
nobody even knew about it until like
seven years ago five to seven years ago
and at the time
it was legal to do so it was legal to do
so it was legal because you just go out
into the ocean and dump whatever because
the ocean is so vast it'll just absorb
whatever toxicity it's faced with and it
reminds me
of that scene in madman do you remember
which one there's one scene in one of
the episodes where
they're having a picnic like on a park
yeah it's got all this food out
like fast food or whatever and then when
they're done they just get up and walk
away and they just leave all their
garbage sitting there on the park
but the drapers were kind of greedy
people but that was a cultural memory of
the time
people used to just throw their paper
drink cup out the window when they were
driving and never think twice about it
well right well that's the big problem
with the plastic in in southeast asia
because it used to be
when you went and got your noodles at
the at the stall
it was wrapped in a banana leaf and you
could throw it out
and nothing would be a problem and now
it's in a plastic bag and for years
people
didn't realize the problems that which
is now it's been corrected now but it
was a cultural thing that had to shift
like give a who don't pollute has to
happen everywhere
so how does this reporter discover this
like this is kind of a big
breaking story i mean it was published
in the la times yeah
and they did kind of one of those
beautiful
graphic photograph heavy uh
you know kind of presentations of it
where it's it's very much a visual story
as
as it is a journalistic story yeah so i
mean i think that
this an academic from ucsb
had kind of was studying methane um
not leaks i guess methane seeps
in the deep water and had had gotten
access to a
rov a robot that could kind of go down
there and study this and they
completed their studies and still had a
little time and i think there
he had a hunch that there was something
going on and there were barrels out
there i mean he'd been following that a
little bit
and he uh was able to locate he and a
research
assistant were able to locate about 60
of these barrels
uh just leaking ddt everywhere and take
samples and periodically people had been
on to this story
but what i think makes the report so
great is that
she spent the time to go back into the
logs and was able to trace them to
montrose
um through the logs and through through
kind of uh
people had still had these files they
still existed right
and so she could trace it to montrose
and montrose had paid 100
plus million dollar settlement to the
epa without
without admitting fault mm-hmm and that
had this one of those beautiful legal
kind of ties ribbons on top which
basically is supposed to anything you
discover
falls under right hand discovery this
discovery doesn't obviate that
settlement like that doesn't expose
them to any additional liability from
what from my read on that story doesn't
seem to be yeah
so but yeah so who's going to clean it
up right so now we're faced with trying
to clean this up
and are these barrels i mean if they've
been down there forever are they still
leaking
they're still leaking apparently ddt
does not dilute very well there
so it depends on the on the samples
they're getting but one sample was 40x
the superfund site
at palos verdes which i've been
to that superfund site offshore on a
boat and you still see people fishing
there
i mean it's like that's and that's the
point right so
we treat the ocean and it's not just us
by the way it's all over the world the
ocean has been treated historically that
way because we didn't have
an understanding because the cul the
dominator culture that we developed in
that we all grew up in
um does not look at things holistically
or no there hasn't
to this point right that's what we all
want to push for we want to push for a
holistic
view of on of land and life and we've
just never gotten there
um and so but what that means is like
people are actually fishing for
you know in areas where fish have come
up with lesions and tumors
you know where sea lions have been found
and dolphins have been found dead
with a high concentrations of ddt in
their blubber
i mean this is all detailed in this
story um and it just makes me think like
you know the way that we view i mean
first of all the ocean
gives us our every second breath and
we're treating it like a dumping ground
and we just got to change that it has to
change well there's just this sense that
it's so vast that we can't possibly harm
it
and yet you know fishing has become
overfishing by definition
we've we've completely overfished the
oceans
the the statistics on the denigration of
coral reefs are like staggering i just
read
something like the other day about how
half of the great barrier reef is now
dead
half of it we are past that tipping
point where
every additional strain on the ocean has
very serious downstream implications and
we've got to reverse this
it's unbelievable yeah we treat this
resource in this way
and it's really a mindset shift as much
as it is anything else
yeah i mean we're to we're we're at a
point now where
um we know what the ocean does for us
right
it's it's absorbing carbon it's it's
giving us
food it's giving us oxygen um we know
that
and yet even today there are companies
lining up to try to
something called deep sea mining to get
precious minerals we needed our tech
and in in in remote south pacific
countries that are giving them the
permits it's all lined up to go
and we don't know the ramifications of
the silt that's going to come up from
that
how that will affect life at the deep
sea or in the mid sea
it's happening right now and we just
make this mistake over and over again
um this idea of short-term gain
financially
for uh for a long-term problem that we
have to live with like ddt
they didn't think this that's the thing
is the people dumping this ddt
didn't think it was going to hurt the
ocean like you said right but they were
cutting they were
they were coming they were they were
cutting corners this was a shortcut yeah
and if the barrels didn't sink let's
just poke holes in them and let the
ddt flow out i mean they had to know
like this is not good but like who's
ever going to find out
you know right and to your point of this
being kind of
um an example of
the importance of cleaning house on an
individual level it's the idea that
these corners that we cut or these
things that we
try to push aside and and rationalize
always come back yeah right the ddc is
always found
yeah it doesn't it doesn't break down no
right it remains there
and it took many years but it was
ultimately discovered
so how do you think about how that
applies to
our individual responsibility well i
mean i think
we as a culture i see it i see it in a
lot of different
places where um we
we don't want to take responsibility
because it's
a lot of work and um on an individual
level
sometimes we don't want to do the little
things at the house and
and batten down the hatches and you know
like put away the clothes
and right or put the recycling stuff in
the recycling and do the composting and
all of that
we don't want to because it's a pain in
the ass but if you don't do those kinds
of things
there are ripple effects in the future
you could look at the supreme court
justice
that's happening right now right like
we're putting someone on the supreme
court
um in a way that was uh obama was not
allowed to put his
justice on the supreme court because it
was election season the republicans are
doing the opposite are doing the exact
opposite of what they said
was right then and we're putting someone
on the supreme court
who doesn't tell us how she feels about
things and we've we've gotten to the
point where it's so partisan like
ruth bader ginsburg was 97 to 3 approved
bork was 100 or something and we're
putting someone on there that is
completely partisan just like kavanaugh
forced through completely partisan and
these kinds of things have ripple
effects you know like
we're not nope both parties don't want
to even
uh clean control their own house their
own damage
yeah fork was a hundred to zero
something like that
and he didn't make it because he smoked
a little pot it's something like that
right yeah
i think that's what it was yeah it
derailed him they derailed him yeah yeah
and so i don't know i think you have to
clean your own house
um or it will come back and and bite you
your house will burn down and so we're
at the point now with us where
where we do need to understand what
we're doing to our land
understand what we're doing to our
people understand what we're doing to
our food we need to make
big changes now because uh you know it's
tick-tock with climate change tick-tock
with nature
and um the more closely we can align
with nature the more time
the more we can vote in favor of the
ocean and
in favor of nature it will benefit us
in the end it's not really a choice
anymore
yeah you know which makes the election
all the more
pertinent because of this issue if for
no other issue
yeah all right let's move on moving on
yeah what do we got now
the teachable moment we should point out
that the arctic ocean
still is not frozen oh right in late
october record dates
no freezing no no ice in the arctic i
don't know or something
maybe not it's not like right you're
just tired bro
because this is a a film review podcast
yes right we had to do the documentary
the documentary that we selected to talk
about in this edition
is the perfect weapon on netflix
which is a pretty compelling deep dive
into um cyber warfare
how it originated the current state of
cyber warfare the implications of it and
what the future looks like
i watched it the other night i was
terrified
at what i discovered and what i learned
how did it land for you
yeah um my biggest takeaway is that i
want to see the interview now
oh the interview the movie the movie
yeah
the spoken movie the movie is basically
it kind of traces the origins
of of cyber warfare and and you know
kind of breaks down what exactly
this is about and takes us up to the
present
and how how
nation-states are are kind of
weaponizing
hacker communities to disrupt countries
like ours and it it starts with
a dissection of the stuxnet virus which
is
the first time that the united states
used
cyberware warfare techniques in an
offensive way
as opposed to kind of you know defending
our systems against
being hacked they actually were able to
infiltrate iran's nuclear program
which was completely blocked off from
the internet right what do they call
that like uh
air gapped where all the computer
systems are not networked and not
connected to
any outside internet access somehow they
were able to get a thumb drive
into one of these computers and it
disrupted their systems
but did it in such a subtle way that it
was somewhat
imperceptible and allowed the united
states to kind of
tweak with their machinery and their
equipment to
derail it yeah grounded their reactors
to a halter basically
yeah basically it begins there then
that's the cyber pearl harbor right yeah
basically and and it gets leaked
this this virus somehow it gets leaked
and people become aware of what they
that's why we've heard of it right the
stuxnet virus
and the next time that it gets used in
accordance with the
the way the documentary tells the story
is with the
the when iran hacks the sands casino
right because uh adelson right sheldon
adelson
well he went on television and spoke
sideways about iran in a non-flattering
way something about
he wanted to bomb right we should deploy
nuclear weapons to their deserts and who
cares anyway and that was deeply
offensive to iran for obvious reasons
so they patiently take their time
uh looking into his you know sans casino
empire this is a guy who's a billionaire
venetian basically and figure out
a vulnerability find their way in and
completely you know disrupt his entire
operation
that way really out of spite yeah they
they took like they were in there for
like two weeks and like
really took their time to figure out how
to destroy it or something that's not
right or is that the new thing yeah they
they were patient i mean i think that's
a hallmark of all of this like
it doesn't have to happen overnight they
wait they wait they wait
they do their homework and it cost them
40. the important point being
the asymmetry here because we're a
superpower and we put so much money into
defense
does not make us in pregnantable
to these attacks that can be launched by
a small
number of young people who have advanced
computer hacking skills so it doesn't
take a
you know a smaller nation state or a
third world country
to be to completely you know derail a
superpower
yeah when you have this capability which
is not that expensive
right right and they were i mean these
were state agents that did that and it
cost i think what it cost them 40
million dollars they said and then north
carolina
north carolina north korea excuse me
north carolina
north korea did the same thing right
when because the interview
was the next thing that queued up which
was basically
a comedy about a guy with a popular
interview show
that um kim jong-un happens to be a fan
of
right james franco plays the character
of a talk show host a controversial
kind of outspoken talk show host seth
rogen is his producer
the concept for the movie is is kim
jong-un
is a fan of the show and wants to get on
so they travel to north korea
to have him on the program and it's a
satirical
and the government says well if you're
going to do that like we want you to
assassinate them right yeah so that's
the setup for
a satirical comedy that
that seth rogen and his writing partner
sell the sony set up at sony and it's
going forward
north korea gets wind of this they're
not happy
and that's what sets in motion what
ultimately became
the big hack of sony that we're all
aware of where all the emails were
exposed
and computers were 70 of the computers
were basically destroyed
right it cost them tens of millions of
dollars um they had like
a snipey like uh producer gossip and
racism accusations and all sorts of
nastiness that was seeping out
and some of that leaked out to the media
but then some of it was leaked out to
wikileaks and that's one of the big
takeaways for me
uh for this is that wikileaks was very
available to north korea and russia
mm-hmm to do their bidding yeah that's
interesting and
um i've always thought that about
assange it's like
you know there are people on on the
progressive left who like to think of
assange as this guy he's all about civil
liberties and let us see the dirty
secrets of the governments and i guess i
understand that but at the same time as
he's got
he's basically become an agent for other
governments
with zero transparency and i mean
there's no other way to read that when
he's taking
fruits of russian hacks of the dnc which
is the next thing that's in this
documentary
or the north korea hacks of uh sony
um i mean what other way is there to
look at at wikileaks other than a
political
operation right so it fast forwards to
the dnc
yeah and basically takes us up to
present
by demonstrating the evolution of these
tactics from
what were originally you know basically
inserting viruses
into networked computer systems to now
a virus of ideas right by by basically
propagating
um memes and other kind of uh
you know ideas fake news into you know
into people's social media feeds
the people themselves then do the work
of the hacker for them by
amplifying these messages that
essentially pit people against each
other and destabilize our institutions
yeah we've been hacked basically right
we as a people
yeah not in the sense of our computers
necessarily being hacked but we've
our consciousness has been hacked the
result being
the disruption of the stability of our
nation which is the
the the goal that they're trying to
achieve it's always been the goal right
right
and and you even see that in the in the
handshake
between putin and trump where you could
totally see putin is the alpha in that
hand that famous photograph you know and
he's basically
they want the country to flail right
yeah
well the alarming kind of takeaway and
the reason for bringing it up
is that this is not going away and
these methodologies are only becoming
um more uh
savvy and sophisticated less easy to
detect
and more virulent with time so it's not
going away
and i don't know that there's much that
we as individuals can do other than to
make sure that our own houses are in
order yeah in terms of our own
security etc and understanding that
anything that you share online is
is there forever i think is also
important um
and to know that you need to
approach the information in your
timeline
with critical thinking skills
because we don't always know where these
things are coming from which brings up
you know another thing that i wanted to
talk about which is the
advent of deep fakes there was a podcast
last week
sam harris's podcast with a woman called
nina schick
who is an expert in the emerging
technology around deep fakes and i think
it's quite terrifying
as this technology continues to develop
and iterate on itself
the idea that videos you watch
people can be manipulated to say
and do anything and it's not going to be
very long before we bridge the uncanny
valley and
it will be imperceptible to the eye and
the ear whether something is real or
something has been fabricated
and with that comes the most
virulent power to disrupt society
because when you can't trust the
veracity
of anything that you see or hear where
does that leave us in terms of our
ability to communicate let alone
run a functional society what is to
prevent
somebody from weaponizing that
technology
to pit world leaders against each other
and
lead us to the brink of nuclear
annihilation like it truly is
terrifying and much like doping in
sports
the technology is always in advance of
the detection methodology
what do you think what's this i think
it's scary i you know i think about my
kids my youngest daughter
and i wonder about the world that she's
going to inherit where when you see a
video of somebody speaking
you have to think is that really the
person did they really say that
and myself is somebody who's in the
public sphere who
has recorded thousands of hours on the
internet and
been on lots of videos how hard would it
be once this technology
is is adequately sophisticated to make
me say
anything and have it appear to be real
so on a personal level
it's scary but you know
think about you know anybody saying
anything
i think the one takeaway i have on that
is that
i mean my hot take is that tech doesn't
work that well and
hopefully it'll just won't you'll see
glitches you'll see the glitch
you would hope but ritual listen to this
podcast and
you may think differently after
listening to it i mean that is
i will i will listen to it that is you
know one thing from the movie
that i think could play to this is that
that the reason that we have such we had
a hard time with fake news
here in this country especially during
the 2016 election and even up to the
2018 they kind of stopped it at the 2018
midterms
um was that uh there was a small
office in uh st petersburg russia called
the internet research agency
which was basically sounds like to me a
state
operation but it was with like hackers
that were going in and creating
not even hackers but they were creating
uh real facebook accounts like memes
and yeah and they were like becoming
they were ingratiating themselves into
different forums and they were spreading
these
uh stories um and all the way
up to covid this was going on
and and creating events yeah in real
in the real world where they would
protest they would they would
schedule opposing groups to show up at
the same place at the same time for the
sole purpose of fomen and chaos yeah
and um i think clapper was the
was the head of intelligence at that
time yeah i think he was under
obama and then he stayed on for a period
of time
and he left and the guy that took his
place at least under cyber command
um general nakasoni yeah i mean we
criticized trump a lot we should say
this
nakasoni came in in 2017 i think and did
a much better job
and really cared about securing the 2018
election
and what they did is they went in and
they destroyed ira they destroyed the
internet research
uh whatever is that what they call it uh
agency agency completely destroyed it
um and made them uh basically muted them
right in the run up to 2018 and you know
he
like that's what gives me hope when we
were talking about before is that
there's people like nakasoni out there
who understand it and uh
are up to the task i mean i think the
thing with clapper is that
you know this guy's a septuagenarian or
what he's been in intelligence forever
he's a
traditionalist and these tools are
unlike anything
a guy like that had ever seen in his
career it's it's
it's not his fault that he was
ill-equipped to be able to deal with it
because
it's so new and different from
traditional warfare methodologies that
he was reared upon
reared on totally it feels like a
gladwell thing waiting to happen
like clapper the old guard who's like
really brilliant and has had this great
career but couldn't handle this he kept
getting
you know he kept getting bested yeah
even after he
you know was surprised of what was
actually going on he was always
playing catch-up and coming from behind
he was in north korea
um negotiating for the release of
prisoners while
sony was being hacked right that's
that's put in there right
another not necessarily relevant aside
is that
one of the primary talking heads in this
movie the perfect weapon
is a woman called amy ziegert who uh is
somebody that i
dated in my 20s briefly that i do
i haven't talked to her in a very long
time but she's essentially
a genius graduated magna laude at
harvard did a fulbright scholarship in
hong kong
worked at mckinsey which in new york
city for a couple years which is where i
met her
then went and got her phd in political
science at stanford
i believe condoleezza rice was her
thesis advisor
and she became very close with condi and
amy has
uh you know done a lot behind the scenes
for
i think a couple administrations and
served unofficially in
a variety of capacities became a
professor at ucla and is now
a professor at the business school at
stanford and she's also
a member of the hoover institute which
is a conservative
think tank but she's distinguished
herself as one of the leading world's
leading experts on
cyber threats cyber warfare cyber
terrorism
and basically in counterintelligence at
large
and was just cool to see her in the
movie yeah speaking so
eloquently um and informed about the
gravity
of this predicament this situation that
we find ourselves in
yeah she was great i mean the fact that
there's all these brilliant minds kind
of coalescing around
the stuff has to be encouraging although
the deep fakes
does sound scary it is um but it's okay
man you have a really cool podcast so
you know i'm sure she knows about it no
it's a cool podcast until the deep fakes
make me say something yeah that i never
said yeah and then then we're gonna get
a lot of phone calls for the
listener questions yeah um
all right cool so we ready to take a
break for a minute let's take a break
we'll take a break we'll be back
with a little show-and-tell and listener
questions
and more goodness boom
show-and-tell all right we're back hey
show-and-tell what do you got for me
well we got the book we did it already
go first
i'm not gonna redo it he already did the
whole book voicing change i had it all
open here what happened i got pushed
away
that's my big show and tell all right
get the book but we already talked about
that so
i'm not gonna belabor that point what do
you got i got my
goggins it t-shirt
[Laughter]
so david goggins just released his
swag line his apparel line yes in fact
i'm going to take goggins it
coat off uh goggins it you know because
it's good for me because
the first i ever heard of david goggins
was on your wonderful neighborhood
podcast
uh-huh and after hearing about it
after hearing him talk about his
100-mile run because at the time i'd
i hadn't started running again from a
foot injury and
i thought no i can't like or no from a
yeah from an
original foot injury and i can't i can't
run and uh
hearing that i'm like okay i'm gonna
start running and uh april and i started
saying goggins it to each other whenever
you wanted to quit
in a in a workout or something right and
so the fact that goggins it
is is inaugural clothing line basically
what was happening was people were
putting out a bunch of uh
clothes using like taking souls
and using his kind of oh they were kind
of
pirating him pirating and sometimes
sometimes they would just put it out
there sometimes they'd say hey is this
cool and he'd have to say no
and they'd have to scrap it um i mean
even rock even sylvester stallone put
out round 14 t-shirts you can go on
sylvester stallone's website and you can
buy round 14 t-shirts so obviously
that's a
connection to goggins in his book um
and so he's like i might as well do it
myself and so he's got this great line
of you know using his phrasing and he
has a this
kind of trident style dg
um he's got this logo that's that that's
a trident
and i've got it it's in the blackout
form this is the
logo and then taking souls in the back
and so it's his
favorite his best catch phrases he's got
a merry christmas shirt it's great i
mean
it's fun it's fun clothing it fits well
i love it it's uh so
shopdavidshop.davidgoggins.com
good for you and i bought this by the
way this is not sure this is not schwags
he didn't send it to you as his
co-author no because i want you know i
support
right to support the fam that's cool
well good for him man
especially you know his whole thing
is speaking gigs now right so with covet
i would imagine he's probably not doing
as much of that
as he could be ordinarily and yeah
he's doing okay gotta make a living is
he yeah yeah it's cool
here's the one thing here's the one
thing that that here's here's the one
you know thing that keeps coming up for
me though yeah
is would david goggins ever wear anybody
else's
line no he never did he always wore a
plane yeah with anybody else's statement
on it so people that
truly want to be goggins-esque would
eschew
that would they not yeah but there's
something inspirational about him that
like for me like goggins it is perfect
because it's like that's
it's something that i actually created i
thought of it myself like without even
knowing it was something
and i think he's kicking around l.a
right now yeah
uh a buddy of mine texted me the other
day and he he was out running
somewhere in los angeles i won't say
where and he came across
goggins who passed him and so he ran to
catch up to him
and he said hey david can i pace you for
a little bit and he goes
no i run alone and he just darted off
which i respect yeah man as somebody who
enjoys my alone time running
and he uh he's running he was running
only a few days after the 240 mile
race right that's what's crazy yeah
because it's only been like a week and a
half
two weeks yeah something like that yeah
and i i heard some stories about
about the race it was uh yeah incredible
taking souls he's out there doing it and
so uh yeah so don't worry about his
speaking
gigs he's he's doing selling some books
good i'm glad yeah
um all right what are we doing are we
doing let's uh listen to questions
let's go for it okay here's randall from
nebraska
hey rich and adam this is randall from
nebraska i need to ask both of you guys
it is a question for both of you
how do you handle when you get burned
out
i've been running primarily road running
i did my first marathon and i really
thought i was going to make
the end of the year trying to get 2020
in 2020
and i'm just feeling burned out and i'm
not sure what to do
to rejuvenate i've been more vegan than
normal
just curious rich and adam have outer
thanks for the show i appreciate what
you guys do
that's a great question randall i think
it's very relatable
and also not surprising if you do any
one thing for too long
you're gonna burn out or at a minimum
get stale
right and if you want to
have longevity in whatever it is that
excites you
you have to take breaks or you have to
mix it up in order to rejuvenate
yourself so
my first piece of advice would be to
loosen your rigidity
around the road running is there a trail
can you go running on a trail
can you get on a bike can you go do yoga
you know virtually through some class
online like find a way
to spice up your regimen
to keep it fresh and ultimately if all
you're doing is running all the time
a not only are you going to get tired of
it b
it's not going to make you the best
runner that you can be
i think the best athletes are the ones
that
are connected enough to themselves to
understand when
they're starting to get stale and
innovating on their routine to
make them a more like resilient athlete
through functional fitness
strength training core training other
types of
exercises both endurance and strength
oriented
flexibility oriented that ultimately
you know keep you engaged in your
fitness journey
um because sustainability is
the name of the game right if all you're
doing is one thing and you're sick of it
at this point
you're not going to be able to go the
distance unless you interrupt that
routine
with new and fresh things like not to
belabor goggins but
look at what david does like yeah he
runs crazy amounts and i think he
sets an example that most people are
never going to be able to live up to but
he's also in the gym and he's doing
pull-ups and he's
you know he's improvising in hotel rooms
and he's always doing things i think
you know for his own sanity keep him you
know engaged in what he's doing by not
it just being
very you know monochromatic or
one-dimensional
and that's just exercise stuff but yeah
i mean you know
keeping it fresh in your life can be go
i think tapping back into the beginner
mind
and you know do something pick up
something that you're really a beginner
at and if you've run a marathon and
you're good at distance running
maybe that's not it maybe like rich is
saying
uh picking up a different fitness
modality but it could also be something
completely unrelated to fitness you know
taking a cooking class or
doing something completely different
just to kind of refresh your mind
there's something about being new at
something i'm this kind of hit me when
i've been kind of in the same old rut of
swimming and free diving and writing and
that's kind of what my whole life was
and
um went and volunteered at the wildlife
center
near your place and was helping with
marine mammal rescue
and feeding marine mammals and i'm like
doing something completely different
i never thought i would do it and um and
it just like completely
lit me up it was like so fresh and
different new
that i loved it i mean even volunteering
so i would i would keep a real open mind
the new thing doesn't even have to be
fitness related it could be anything
right i think that's a great point you
know on the on the fitness tip though i
remember
when i finally retired when i retired
from swimming and call
like i never thought i'd swim again i
was so over it like the idea of jumping
into a swimming pool just seemed
like the last thing that i would ever
want to do and the idea that i found my
way back to it and figured out a new way
to fall in love with it
was something i never would have
predicted but also
something i don't think i would have
been able to perpetuate if i'd just gone
back to swimming like it was
triathlon the the mix of those three
disciplines that always keeps it fresh
like if i was just riding my bike or
just running
i think i would you know have difficulty
perpetuating that so
you know that's an example of mixing it
up within something that still
is you know a sport itself but the idea
of going out of your comfort zone and
trying new things i think is super
important
like you hit in the gym with the weights
again throwing weight around yeah
exactly
and that and that's also a function of
feeling a little bit you know not
rejuvenated around doing the
same thing that i've been doing for like
over a decade at this point
right like and this guy's run on you
know randall it sounds like you've
you've done
one marathon so you know there's an
argument to be made that you're
you're still in the starting gate of
this exploration of running and the fact
that you're already
having difficulty motivating yourself i
think is a pretty strong indicator that
you need to figure out
a different relationship with this
discipline that can keep you you know
engaged and a lot of it
is you know i i don't know him i don't
know you well enough to
presume anything and i don't want to
overly
project but um if you're
feeling burned out after one marathon
perhaps you're putting too much pressure
on yourself or you're too performance
oriented that it feels laborious or like
a chore
rather than being something that should
be fun and should bring your life joy
so if you can recalibrate your
relationship to it so you're approaching
it
and embracing it from a perspective of
joy and
exploration and curiosity as opposed to
a rigid relationship where you're
you know wed to your garment and caught
up in the numbers
and overly focused on performance gains
yeah um i think you'll find uh you know
perhaps an opening
to enjoy it a little bit more i love
that your advice about trails
because it could be the roads right when
he lives in nebraska
so i don't know what the trail situation
is where he lives but
maybe there's still still you know get
off the road maybe yeah
okay let's hit missoula montana
hey adam hey rich my name is robel and
i'm from missoula montana
i got kind of a unique name and i'm kind
of just curious if you've ever met
another robel
um my parents gave it to me and i have
yet to find another one so that'd be
kind of cool to know
if you know robel out there but anyways
i had a question in regard to
navigating living in alignment with your
values
um i know that there's some
issues a lot of issues with corporations
big ag all those things but in terms of
like corporations
is it consid would you consider it
living in alignment with your values if
i'm not purchasing on say
amazon to get all my things but i have a
roth ira
with stock in amazon and i'm making
money and i'm kind of vested in that
community
i'm just having trouble kind of
navigating if it's even possible
to perfectly live in alignment with your
values
and i'm just curious if you're that anal
or maniacal about it
or do you just do your best part thank
you so much i appreciate your guys's
work
and uh roll on thanks guys i don't know
another robel do you
i've never met another robel you're my
you're our first robot yes
the very first you'll always have a
place in our heart
for that alone robel from missoula um
it's an aspiration
you can't if you become overly rigid
with these things you're going to drive
yourself crazy the idea
is to always be striving to
improve to bring your actions into
greater alignment with those values but
i think if you're
overly stringent or strident
about the minutia ultimately you know my
answer is not
dissimilar from the response we gave
randall like you're going to burn out
and it won't be sustainable because
you're not going to be able to
adhere to it over the long haul and i
think getting caught up
in the details in the minutia is to
threaten losing sight of the bigger
picture so all we can do
is try to tackle the biggest
levers the most important the most
impactful things that we can do
to align those actions with our values
and
understand that nobody's perfect we we
live in a material world nobody is
living
without making some kind of impact
on the planet deleterious
um the idea is to try to reduce that
but if you lose sight of the forest for
the trees and get caught up in
like the diapers like adam was you know
we talked about you talked about like
the diaper situation with you and like
and
and being you know caught up in that
like yes but in the grand scheme of
things like you're doing
more than most and you know i would say
adam that you're
in relatively very good alignment with
those things
but not everything is gonna is gonna
fall into place perfectly my diaper game
could
be upgraded yeah you could yeah asher my
buddy osher texted me what's up asher
and said
so tell adam to relax a little bit about
the diapers
he's doing good he might thank you thank
you asher um
on the other hand i've gotten like three
messages this week
different advice but always very kind
and nice advice helpful good
and i will we will upgrade but um i
didn't expect to talk about diapers with
robel's question
um i agree i think um
you know it's it's it's a it's always
gonna be a moving target there's always
your life's gonna change it's gonna
expand and contract it's it's nothing is
is static and so um you do the best you
can
i think there are ways to be the most
impactful
is is kind of like bring your own and
looking at your diet and things like
that that's probably
the diet is probably the single best way
you can make a move on
right if you big police yeah taking a
tip
from like the drawdown yeah blueprint
playbook
focus on the things that move the needle
the most and
moving towards a more plant-rich
plant-centric diet is a huge thing
if you can develop a garden and start
growing
some of your food like these are huge
things and
not getting caught up in like well i
ordered this thing from amazon and i
should it's like yeah there's better
ways of doing everything
right i think that the interesting
existential dilemma that he's pointing
to though which i
share is that the market economy
is kind of problematic for
sustainability i mean it's problematic
for
a more egalitarian society the fact that
the stock market dictates so much of the
moves companies make
is the reason that they squeeze wages
it's the reason that
wage growth has not kept up with uh ceo
pay even close
it's a reason that we have um
environmental problems and
and and a political landscape where
money is buying votes
uh you know in favor of special
interests all this comes back
to the market economy and
so you know if if if you're being good
about
not buying stuff through amazon because
of the
extra packaging and you're vested in
amazon as a stock
you know what are you doing and i am
sympathetic to that because for a long
time i wasn't an amazon
customer at all i did become an amazon
customer now like
to be completely transparent a good part
of my living is
based on sales through amazon the book
sales
so uh you know like
i'm i'm i'm a party to all of that and i
do understand that
the tension there and like like does
that align with who i am
and um you know i mean to be quite
honest with you i stopped thinking about
it that much
you know and i just tried to keep it
more simple than that
but i like that robel that you're
bringing it up because i think it is
it is fair to bring up and i understand
where you're coming from and i don't
have a perfect answer for you
mm-hmm yeah i think we'd all benefit
from doing
an honest objective inventory of
our behaviors and our kind of daily
practices and how they
implicate these problematic systems but
we live in a capitalist society
and you know short of of completely
reconfiguring
you know how we live our lives and the
way our government functions
there's going to be you know things that
we do
that are not great right and all we can
do
is try to continually you know iterate
on
what we do to you know bring those
things closer into
alignment there you go i mean there are
shareholder activists that
kind of like that try to organize
shareholders to go and push
companies towards a per a social or
environmental goal there is kind of that
whole movement as well
um it'll be interesting to see where
things go but i guess the short answer
is
not that maniacal or anal about it right
but robel
could become an activist shareholder and
start accumulating lots of shares of
amazon yeah and then he can show up at
the shareholder meeting and make a big
stand and
and beezus would have to talk to you
right
okay last one we're going down to
fullerton
california hey everything adam my name
is evan i'm 26 and i live in fullerton
california
i've been a big fan of the podcast for a
few years now a few years now
and as a graduate student pursuing my
master of public health degree
these discussions are very inspiring in
my early 20s i experienced some body
dysmorphia issues and
even developed somewhat of a revenge
eating disorder as a result of competing
in bodybuilding shows
i was just wondering what your thoughts
are on eating disorders among males
and if this is also an issue that you
encountered within the ultra marathon
community
over time i've developed a better
relationship with food however
i believe that it is an issue that needs
more discussion
especially among males so thank you both
so much for taking questions and for all
that you do
thanks that's a great question evan i'm
really grateful
for this question because i do think
that it's kind of
a a sleeping lion or an elephant in the
room that doesn't get
enough air time or discussion there's
plenty of conversations around
um eating disorders in females
um and it's almost never discussed
how that dysfunction impacts men but i
think it
impacts tons more than tons of dudes
i think more so now than ever with
social media and everything oh yeah
100 so whether you're a bodybuilder
or a gym rat who's trying to you know
basically you know inhabit an impossible
physique or you're a runner or you're a
triathlete or a cyclist
who's trying to drop weight and get
super crazy lean
and i've been part of that community
i've noticed those tendencies in myself
i've seen it in other people
and basically it i think it's
i don't know if i would call it an
epidemic but i think it's a very real
thing
that doesn't get enough air time or
discussion
and i think it's important to shed light
on the fact that it does exist and it
exists in numbers i think that would
surprise
a lot of people um i there's a swimmer i
know named antonio arguelles who
was the seventh ever to do the ocean
seven um
the seven channel swims around the world
mexican swimmer i've written about
uh before for the new york times and
then i actually helped him write his
book which is published in spanish in
mexico and i think there's an e-book in
english now
called the forever swim and he tells the
story a similar progression to you he
came up in swimming
in um mexico and ended up swimming at
stamford
um but when he was in high school he he
moved
to northern california and high school
um
you know as a way to kind of train and
try to get better and make the olympic
team
and in senior year his times were
suffering because he
he was a bigger guy yeah and he had um
he had bulimia
and he never talked to anybody about it
he's just kind of recently started to
talk to people about it and he has a lot
of heart for people who are like
chubbier kids that are athletes um you
know you just don't
see that many that are there are a lot
of great athletes that are just bigger
guys
and so he had that a lot so antonio
arguelles is someone i think you should
look to and right and and he's
accessible
online um so that's the first experience
i had with talking to someone about it
in depth and it was he was suicidal he
had all sorts of issues with it
and he was able to write himself um and
and
and but you know it takes therapy
sometimes
yeah yeah i don't know of a prominent
male athlete or otherwise who's taken
this
cause up to speak about it publicly at
a high level maybe there is somebody
who's doing that i'm not sure
but somebody certainly should and i
would couch this by saying
that um i'm certain
that the eating disorder statistics
um would show that this is this is
a much bigger problem among women like
the pressure on women to adhere to a
certain
physique and the appearance pressures
that they're shouldering
outweighs what males endure for sure
yeah so i want to be sensitive to that
but at the same time
i think it's important to acknowledge
that this is a very real problem
among males and i think in you know
instagram culture is exacerbating this
when you see ripped dudes and
photoshopped images of of guys and
i think there is more pressure on men
and young men to
look a certain way and there's a more
robust like kind of body conscious
culture around
males than there used to be maybe even
five or ten years ago
no doubt about it so um so
let's talk about this more i should i
should maybe try to find
somebody to come on the podcast and talk
about i mean i've talked about this
with some women athletes i had amelia
boone on and i had dotsy bausch but i've
never had a guy come on
totally affects performance i mean
antonio um
he writes about it in his book all about
his experience at senior year
level and he was trying to compete for
an olympic spot at that point you know
like
and and to see his times erode it took a
while though he was able to still
succeed for a while before his body
really started to suffer
breakdown break down yeah um
i think it's a great question and i
appreciate your kind of being trans
open on this subject i i want to just
say to all the young listeners out there
i do feel for you guys this this covet
thing is just continuing to drag on
it's a real bummer and um i feel for
like people seven
to 27 right to be honest with you like i
can't imagine
having to deal with that at a young age
you know when i
you know i mean it's easier for us
because we have a stable life and we
have
way we don't we're not we're not in that
like young people need the community a
little bit even more
and rely on it and um and so i really
feel for you guys and
and uh thinking about you guys yeah i
agree
um i had a final thought i wanted to
share about that
yeah i think um oh well two things first
of all in the case of
of the guy that you wrote about
one of the good things is that when you
become a marathon swimmer like you've
got to get
you kind of got to get fat that's right
he calls it his bioprint yeah you get to
put on a ton of weight because you need
that fat layer to keep you warm in the
open water yeah
all the open water marathon swimmers are
like big people
they tend to be but there's like kim
chambers even thinks that that there's
it's like the same idea with yardage
equals faster times was an old
concept in swimming uh you know in
training right human yardage
she thinks that's uh an outdated concept
of marathon swimming that's interesting
yeah but she's just kind of
yeah after doing it is when she's
realized that yeah
and when you look at sports like
wrestling boxing
mma uh and cycling and triathlon
where weight is is you know highly
pertinent whether you're trying to cut
weight to make weight
for a fight or you're focused on your
power to weight ratio which is critical
in cycling it's all about like getting
as lean as you can without sacrificing
power and finding that
finding that inflection point and most
people take it too far
i got too thin at one point i was like
158 going into the
2011 ultraman um
and when you're in that state you don't
realize that you're too light like
you're just like i can get lighter
you know and it's dysfunctional and you
know i immediately put weight back on
after that and i've never
gone to that place again but i can see
how it happens and being an addictive
personality
myself who's had issues with food you
can lapse into this
and it takes on an energy of its own and
becomes a thing before you have any
objective perspective on it and i think
with dudes you can hide it or because
there's not a permissiveness around
talking about it
that it perpetuates more than it should
because
you know dudes don't feel confident
being vulnerable with other dudes like
hey i have an eating disorder like
you just don't hear those conversations
in a male locker room or
anywhere else and to the extent that we
can
create a welcome environment for those
conversations to happen i think we could
you know all be better off evan's
starting it right now
he is so evan thank you for that
sir um i think we did it are we done we
did it let's talk to another one
i think this might be the most succinct
roll-on that we've done is it we're
going to land on this plane
how long have we been at it it's been a
while
yeah we've been here for a while are you
bored of yourself
i'm never bored of my own my own
speaking voice i could keep going
i feel good and as we head into the
election a week from now
i maintain my optimism me too i believe
i believe i believe in i believe in
three things
the lakers the dodgers and old joe one
down
one on the brink and old joe bringing up
the rear i believe in
i believe in myself the american people
oh and our democratic institutions
vote for dolphins and rainbows okay
um cast your vote participate in our
democratic
experiment yeah and we'll catch you on
the other side just
vote it's okay yeah we love you anyway
i love you i love you adam i love you
too rich good
um we'll be back in two weeks with more
roll on
until then uh you can follow adam at
adam skolnik on the socials i'm at
rich roll pick up or pre-order i should
say the new book voicing change
on the new ritual website ritual.comvc
or voicingchange.com uh leave us a
message if you want your
question answered on the show
424-235-4626
don't forget to subscribe to the podcast
on apple spotify and
youtube you could check out the show
notes as always on the episode page for
this episode where we'll have links to
everything that we talked about today
to watch the documentaries and to read
the news articles everything that we
discussed
you can also submit your question on our
facebook group
uh and that's it that's it man
right on be good right on right on right
on right on right on that's right man
to the generally heroic adam skolnik
to the generally heroic ritual i'm going
to call everybody gh now
that's the thing um cool
appreciate the love you guys see you
back here in a couple days
with another great episode until then go
to the ballots
cast your vote if you're an american
if not if you're not an american
congratulations
all right peace plants namaste
[Music]
you